oh thank you um
I
think this item uh is includes the um
review of the
20 in the valuation of property plan and
Equipment um so I guess my questions are
around is that a concern that's ongoing
because this is in the past um um and
where those flaws with the external
value or whether with management within
the
council thank you thank you chair
um let's
begin um it's fair to say that the the
the work that we do around the valuation
of property PL and equipment is now
significantly greater in terms of the
Quantum of work and the depth of
challenge that we put um put your put
your accounts through if you like than
used to be the case a few a few years
ago um that's a result really of changes
in what the regulator expects us to do
around that but also because work over
recent years has identified particular
issues with um
Val
value or is them relying on other
information for what they do and we
there's been some difficulty marrying
the two up I don't I don't think it's
going to get better in the short term
because I think it'll be one of those
things that as you go through your
rolling program evaluations over a few
years you'll start to correct the Bas
data but I think what is important is
there is an understanding now of the
problems um that perhaps hasn't always
has been there so that the two teams
and
the Estates team were brought back in
house uh from from uh
uh to try and straighten these things
out uh we we
are the party advisers and also looking
at the systems and processes as to how
we actually recorded the information to
get it to date to avoid some of these
issues going
forward anybody else any
questions that's call
um just on
the just just to sort of me in terms of
what you're
saying look into the
future are we are we having are we
looking to
got available in order to replenish
those reserves
[Music]
and to just do
because
so in the in the draft budget report
that was um recently um tabled um bra
was
um point of
view all public sector and local
authorities at the moment not you need
um that the need to either find
sustainable savings to to actually bre
even we've got 6 and a half million
pound gapping our draft budget for next
year from something
from
natur wage ands of that so so we're at
that position where it is a precarious
situation that was
emphasized last year's
fin
it's it's not looking
positive Council it looks I
mean it looks to me as though we're
going to get to commentary on financial
sustainability well into the future each
and every year
because I don't I don't think I need a
crystal ball to imagine the conversation
that future Financial leads will be
having
offic you need to spend less than you've
got and actually the financial need
wants to spend more
than I can't see how
we not quite a qualification yet
it's it is going to be listed as a worry
from here
on it stands
on I just come back in on that you will
receive from us a commentary every year
about your
Arrangement
conclusion will
provide very much
depend
exactly
you're the territory
of
two three years down the line that won't
be the T
anymore for to be things know about
coming out of the woodwork that end up
that
res
you're and there
isn't thanks anybody
else well thanks Karen that
that's thank you item seven treasury
management mid year performance Frank
are are you doing that
um so this is the update
of going through some of the
headl so starting
with
borrowing what that
means is the capsule
spend that isn't external
source not back
notes so it's things that
we
F
so that
am that
number
in we'll be taking
off which will assess the the amount
and the
assessed so investment
activity uh similar level
Investments a level of
income
near Target
that's
um terms of the comparison of
that to the nature of
the the increas interest rates from
start quite quite frequently throughout
the year so any any invest C had that's
had longer than a month will
automatically be outdate we're now
caught up as the rates are stabilized so
the latest uh performance were now for
Benchmark for for our investments at
this point in
time so we should probably see improve
when we report this
again indicators are also in this report
uh these will be similar to the the ones
that um so some of these will be
familiar to you
um indicators where there's a limit on
Council
activities none of these breached in the
forecast be breached in the second
half uh so touching on training there
will also be a
um session organized in
January
um
strategy some details will follow on
that and that'll be with
our St close last
year so there'll be someone new this
year but I'll um I'll circulate some
information as we be doing
that I think that's I'll take any
questions
um easy to
understand for in in our terms and um
there's a lot of familiar
organization some
that
of Q8 that I'm just wondering do we have
a any kind of
policy in terms of working out is some a
fit institution
to who's offering bring the best rate at
any particular time which I can
understand is particularly in a
straightened circumstances is is
[Music]
Prim so public money that's the
first
so the uh the council by being short on
cash and why
is
so are also review some of these banks
will place money to look up whether this
is somewhere the council to be
investing
where best and also in terms of
Bank
lending um we also
haveed list based
on
accept
SL
polyc
say AB is going in for gas Investments
then do we have
any carbon footprint you know and there
other itation about people investing
in
these organizations and I don't want you
know to
to you know cast discussions and things
like that but I think it would be us
great
comfort these organizations and I'm sure
that there are ratings out
there soety who are probably investing
one would hope in
more country and that kind
of it's always
very very to answer it and I know we've
had the the debate with uh the bank of
uh Qatar at the time
was a bit more uh as supposed in terms
of responsive to that type of question
um point of view so
soly investigate any other so government
Arrangements
be these measured up against um the
return as well so we can see if we can
investigate
any thank you um couple of
question
first
so the amount of money that council is
investing on capit
investment a
lot and related to that on the following
slide are under
borrowed think the Fig was is
that impact on our future income
generation
the um with
the
so 56 in the left hand
market so
um yes CFR is down
so the
um the capital programs
um around in that threeyear program that
gets set so um it's
reducing
we for 45 and 56 so the CFR is
increasing
in is La in the sche in terms of
the how that
affects
borrowing so we are the amount of income
that we'll be
generating
um to
to
invest it's increasing so that was in
that table it's
um so what we're saying for when we say
that the under borrowed is increased by
over 30 million in the year is that we
are spending more money that is funded
from borrowing on the capital program in
the year and we
on figure we do think should come down
again and that's why we're planning on
taking out some new borrowing before the
end of the year that's not that new
borrowing is not bu this
forecast does
that
um borrow and invest more in income
generating
activities and if that
unlikely that we would be able to
borrow invest it
verely it's it's actually not perm to
borrow in advance of need specifically
to do that so
the
rules Council
it has to
be but it's
unlikely invest the
money Investments to generate a better
return so if we were to borrow the money
and spend it through the ass investment
strategy would classify as
cap 10 million
invest question in terms
of
investment versus
62 as we have an envelope about 500
million pound technically that we can
operate
in terms of the commitment against that
um
technically as long as it meets the
criteria what we're allowed to do with
it so we can't
for
investment
in terms of the original
assumption
not
you attractive withm the rules
Investments to be
made
investment strategy board and the
decision they they review
and the place for that decision to be
made and suppose anything that they feel
uncomfortable with that they
don't feel within
the they start explosing
because
is fluid as they were 12 months ago or
24 months ago
so the outputs from the investment
management
board
scrutinized I'm not quite sure you
mean investing
in
it's part of the um view on that is
not particularly the relationship
which we've got with the three limited
liability uh companies that we operate
there's there's
there so I suppose if there's anything
that you feel you might want to say you
want to have some more update from the
more perhaps Challenge
from
order tring topic along that bit more
detail
the in terms of scrutiny in terms of the
performance of the
Investments the they are the the
portfolio performance is reported five
monthly through the
capital in terms of
the decision making process
itself
again
thanks
the um
so great that's comforting but that's
what
query was the
performance how the decisions are
taken
how those opportunities and who decides
there aren't those opportunities that's
a kind of big mey strategic stuff and
I'm querying whether that's scrutinized
and if it is
set
out for instance uh loan to asset value
so if it um setting tenants long-term
tenants and those
it's for future
G
you know the program
operates within the premises of
security
to come I think it's a really really
good point you made to
have the process
works responsibility here as committee
is and R
management bad decisions that result in
losses so not investing you can't find
the diverse way and
not not
exposing risk as a result of the things
you're doing is more worrying and that's
why you as a committee should be
satisfied that the council
is thank you
uh
position
detailed scrutiny of the Investments
that
um is um
very in-depth work that uh um you on and
that's on the B the decisions of the
Border taken on on that basis but
obviously the scr ability to scrutiny
scrutiny is limited because of the
commercial sensitivity of the deals that
are being discussed so there's always
going to be a limit to what can be said
in here but I definitely agree that we
should you know I mean you know I'm new
to I've only been to one meeting so I I
would benefit from hearing here as well
what we could um you know um how Works
how if it's by an outside
entity and how much
without actually being on the board
you to say whil we can't ask the board
why you invested in x y and Zed
properties but we should be satisfied
that there is a an
overarching policy that we that we
understand how they assess the risk and
how they take
decision get into what those
actual because of the
I think that that is a very fair
point yeah
exactly I'll cover
bit management Cod there certain
activities in there that we' recognized
in the previous
review need to
arangement thanks just reflecting on um
your room where it happens
um to what extent this under
to what extent is that absolutely bang
on
right
scrutiny
line too
cautious
meaning than out in the
streets and under borrowed we we I
think I have some I've fallen into this
trap before so I know that there are
pitfalls in trying to understand the
language but underbed in this does not
mean we need
to borrow
more thing that we're
accounting
temporarily
Capital programs if if you let's say you
buy a bill in
10 you need to finance that in some form
so if money comes in from Grant you say
that reduces we need to need to finance
it um if of the capital
program some of it comes from Capital
receipts
only borrow 50 million it's technically
to 100 million but because of our policy
we said well let's use our internal
resource instead of going out to the
market and
borrow depleted start
external and to go to the
market so that that's
General I can reassure my colleague that
I'm not understanding the difference
between the two from the
orig
it 500 million ceiling on investment for
Generation we're currently using about
three and
all it's it's easy to be cautious it's
more difficult there is a decision
that's been
making wisely and
the question I
was that's I think where I got to in
this yeah I'm glad counil Cy mentioned
that because I think it there's a
certain amount of semantics in that is
it when you say something's under
borrowed it s tends to suggest you're
not
nothing we do need to
uh looking at the individual
Investments okay
thank you
um rate of inflation has fall more
rapidly than had previously
been expected by by
um does that
any or
[Music]
assumptions yeah they
Fallen thought
no they thought the budget
so
of obviously the
big
6% still not falling as quick
as um so so yeah so that's still in
not thank
you can we now pass on to item eight
Insurance performance report
over to you again okay
right so this is the the annual report
that we we do in terms of the uh
Insurance performance uh this is the
last full year 22
2023 um um the claims performance uh
comparable with previous years and
um in terms
of insurance
um
so sorry
page the annex there shows the
various see and lights of that
50,000 Agate stop
L 750 or2 million
pounds actually then then step
in all of the uh uh the immediate access
so in terms of the actual
um it's made up from premiums um
Provisions for claims where we set money
aside
for income that we generate for re
charging for the liks of the
schools so overall
we an underspend of
8,000 managed to top reserve some 161
so in terms of that the revenue budget
that's that's that's a revenue budget
which we
we which is called
insurance this is the amount that
settis storic insurance
claims every every couple years and said
right this is the
evolving claims uh claims that we've had
that haven't
yet
to Insurance risk Reserve um now this is
just basically a mountain we be Mark to
cover
um if we have where for instance we Happ
to uh trigger a large number of claims
have in that
Reserve 7 million three large insurance
claims to cover the excess of those
250,000 and there's an element balance
for municipal uh Mutual insurance which
is a legacy insurance company that all
councils in the country use to get
involved in so we we hold a balance
within that within the figure for that
um and also they actually when when they
do the evaluation of our our
risk
we recommend you set some money aside
for that um so we we we've managed to
build up a sufficient Reserve if we
could do to build up to recognize those
evolving claims so this year's uh budget
we had under spent because of the actual
number of claims were less than
previously so we set aside £61,000 to to
top up that risk Reserve in line with
what they act was
recommended so that's in terms of the uh
um the the budget side of things um in
terms of the claims um in section three
we we've had
556 claims a slight slight increase in
in previous Financial year in
2122 we did see reduction in insurance
claims generally largely because of
covid lockdown obviously traffic was
being reduced in terms of Highway claims
and and the Public Public injury claims
and the liks of that so that was that
was a year U think is obviously getting
back to normal now we've seen an
increase in in the number of claims um
from um 209 to 246 in
2223 um the major claims then covered in
in the following paragraphs of that one
largely we're we're we're not seeing any
major increase um that's that's in any
concern um we've had a couple of Highway
injury claims we've had one one
particular um excess single case that we
we have had to set aside an excess of
275,000 that was uh that was covered for
a for for an injury largely associated
with an individual which had a a high
high income when was off work so that's
why that's that's that's so High um our
property again the picking up obviously
because the traffic's picking up on on
that side of things um in terms of
Highway trees nothing nothing abnormal
from that one it's it's it is low
compared with previous year 25 claims
compared with an average of 46 over the
last 5 years they have been ticking up
as things obviously trees and the Aging
nature of the trees um has been a
subject matter that I know we' discussed
in the past so that has been ticking up
but at the moment the trees claims were
quite low we we did have one claim in in
there regarding the fatality in October
was quite it was it was it was quite a
well publicized
incident dramatic incident um so the um
the health and safety review had found
the council um wasn't subject to any
further investigation but there's an
ongoing coroners inquest on that on that
case um and lastly public liability
claims we've received 17 new ones
against an average of 22 they can
potentially be where your cost base is
um in terms of negligence claims and the
lacks of that um there is a court case
going through at the moment and through
the Supreme Court that's due to be to
due to be heard in terms of settlement
in terms of Damages which might set the
standards across the country from
that
87% 74% to
75 um in terms of the Outlook um the the
issues
counts typ of things can have a
consequence of obviously
you
um we're out to Tender shortly for
the
a an insurance cover for cyber it's the
evolving Market um the the Market's
maturing the gold posts are also
actually being moved as as more risk is
start to be understood um we work with
our office the it function uh they
operate a lot of Social Security
Arrangements in including obviously
software Hardware as well as training to
staff as well so that's a risk we're
trying to trying to manage that within
there so that's uh that's thing that
someone concluded on that
one thanks very much any
questions counc
a yeah I was just going to ask about the
highway injury because she says it's the
largest insurable Financial Risk I
didn't
local
to be kind of if if that is the case and
you know fighting for 20 m per hour Zone
seems to be would help to avert that
risk yeah yes it it was uman I can't
too live case um but it involved um an
individual um tripping over into on on
the on the highway um
and damaged to to to the to the cells so
so the were
uh they were off work for quite a few
months I think so um it's
been there quite considerable loss of
earnings claim so
obviously that is that damage to
pedestrian
isn't
it obviously if it's
on
and a lot of them um and also the
highways act um section 51 allows you to
defend that so that that's something
that's mean you can see from the defense
rates
8 coun C
Reserve 50 value of what
suggest could you
expl
the provision so these are actual
claims
they not yet
been exist yet themes so they were they
were being cautious in saying right we
suggest you should also set aside
um we would they couldn't defend the
case to say whether it set
aside we said well it's not actually
provision because they don't fit the
categorizing at historically the
previous actually didn't even raise it
as as as a top so so we we had quite a
debate over it and said okay
well if we could afford to do it
obviously with
all
versus
that our all of our am reserves are
really Under
Pressure % um and so this is this is the
year
now spend of 161,000
say it wasn't it wasn't a statutory
requirement that you said you have to
put it side but we were being cautious
so we did the middle ground and said
let's work towards 50% of it
am I being delivered not about we feel
as so it's sufficient to cover all of
those looking at
the
um you've got Highway
injury trees and I suppose my question
is Highway trees
so terms of them being a different
category I
know a tree root sticking out that um
was be what category would like a a
broken pavement with a tree root would
that be a highway tree or that be um one
of the other categories the highway
property categories I'm just trying to
understand and you've also said further
question about the trees you've also
said that you had a health and safety
investigation on the trees so I'm just
wondering what what did you do to the
trees to make them
safer yeah that's yeah um yeah so so ter
in terms of the C categories how Highway
property is where somebody's damaged D
the car for instance if they've gone in
a Poole and they damaged the tire so
that's that's that's the property not
necessarily high cost ones obviously
repairing a tire or or car suspension or
something like that can be can be high
volume but low cost so in terms of our
categorization
frequency of inspections and
all so was that a fatality due to a
tree yes what what what what had
happened the the the the tree were was
on was on was on the highway um the the
conclusion from the um the health and
safety executive they had a tree expert
come in to to review and um
the the conclusion was that when the
tree was planted it was potentially
planted to too deep and it was something
that you couldn't actually for foreseen
at the time um and the root ball of the
tree basically
disintegrated even though the tree
looked healthy um they'd never seen a
case like it so they really completely
baffled them as to how the tree could
look so healthy and it' been inspected
um it' been um been reviewed only
recently been it was in Full full leaf
and uh so there wasn't anything to
suspect that the tree was damaged in any
way
whatsoever um it wasn't even particular
windy day so all the circumstances but
for some reason is just pure from
obviously horrendous consequences it
literally just gave away so so
the
[Music]
um where the Ed for that so we're in the
process of introducing a new tree
database
and been done years strategy would look
at frequency
of back
end
the amount we spend with our insurers do
we get anything back in terms of sort
of um minimize risks and secondly do um
obviously we seem to be defending a
large proportion of cases um but does
that still have a cost that we can't
actually recruit um in terms of you know
legal fees or
whatever
the
ultim to make sure that we're managing
those
C you know for
instance to to defend that case
um not going
to time depending on the case but that
that those initial costs are born
largely by the council because we very
rarely exceed
those need to draw insurance premium
very
few um so that input
from um for instance
the
lot within
that to your vigilance in terms of your
highways inspection regime of that so
it's in
there so so our insurance team sits with
me
they do offer workshops from
from
okay
everybody
um there's no mention in here of
covid and I'm guessing that in ter terms
of B is there at the currently targeting
government and
all is
is is there a possibility that they
could
potentially there's all I suppose you
can't dismiss the V because asking the
question is probably you know there's
people will be thinking the same and
as to that would say make sure
you side in there so interesting to see
whe
school you know missing school time the
of
that
we move on to the next item then which
is the uh the financial management code
update right this this
is FM
code one
um it was basically introduced by by the
government um in terms of um picking
up sustainability of Lo local
authorities um The Joint
with with s try and put together a
framework as to what was examples of
best practice um so that there's seven
sections or seven principles within
there as to what you should be what you
should be looking at in terms of for
instance things like organization
leadership accountability how you manage
your budget what your governance
arrangements are and the likes of that
the detailed in in
in it's not a statutory requirement to
put compliance code is
good it does work on on the self
assessment
questions and then come up
with so this is the this is the second
update
we um last day from July 2022
progress has
been we've got
um on page 96 in terms of uh last year's
action plan where we've made
PR with the the training with Sals month
obv running on next year the things
um so that's that s things in terms of
um progress which is covered on
the further action where we
need
know we need to we need to
improve dat um
sorry did improve on was the report for
the Strategic investment program
giving
companies shareholders the
llps performance of those
so
management we've already talked about
the the
quality property for the maintenance
schedules and the likes of that um we
also recognize we do need
to and tighten up the way we manage the
those assets in terms of looking the
quality and how we actually
develop
capacity resources also included in
there in terms of Mak sure financially
sustainable
can public at the moment but these are
the areas that youve got to make sure
you still progressing to to meet
requirements will
be money statement
to conclude as to how what Road
bus any
questions go
carter
um there's a whole table page after page
compliance ratings on standard
practice
um
comment P it's you're online internal
documents it's slide
116 is page
one page 112 in the left hand
[Music]
margin just see if we can remind myself
what this one is on here this is um
yeah I think this is just a gen General
comment in terms of
the
um
I
anybody
else thanks very much for that thank
you Mark I think isn't it okay
thanks
um um based on information provided to
us over the last
few
um Port PR are
not draw your attention there were three
changes in the period in
Risk time um risk one around the
wial strategy
increase
fing um risk 14 around business
continuity slight increase from a score
of six to nine and that's really
ter with the
departure um
and 1
has been decreased from 15 to
10 development set out in the report and
risk
13 various updates to all the other
detail see in the report
um on certain
risks discussions and we looking to have
a a more
detailed
um also around cyber security risk as
well um for the February meeting um the
chief digital officer is going to go
give on details in the report happen to
to
follow any questions
no oh
sorry I thought a bit slow there
can I was deliberately
slower so just I was hoping to buy 30
seconds time to frame the
question slide 144
so you want to get slide 144
um yeah
so look
and
have in the past and this committee and
the feral scrutiny
committee and the budget next year and
that's all great
um warnings and concerned around medium
term the medium term financial position
so
UNS scrutiny do you
think years two and three
roll in terms of get in regular
um don't Dave wants to
add yeah the
current two
and the financial strategy which updated
in the draft budget
report um and also the final budget
report and
um
[Music]
scy do review The buget
Proposal
um with that's sufficient for you
to
from the scrutiny
committee as part of the final budget
P there
is is that
aspect thank you and if I could yeah
just ask the question I was originally
going to ask um when I
was on slide 144 so that is Page 140
in Risk
number there's discussion about a
specif
spending and going to deficit is
accelerating
D which
need Poss
growing is it possible to see any
options the council has considered for
capping this
Bend hugely amount and contenent but
purely from a final point of
view what we are saying is we got a find
out amount of
money we're going to spend over spend
this year we know next year more than
spend this year and by the way
trafford's nowhere near anywhere near
the worst of this we're one of the best
at this and yet because of the limits on
resources
versus demand lead so I think the the
the hard-headed Financial question is
are there any options on how to cap them
and more than happy to have an answer at
a future meeting if if you don't no I
can answer the broad the broad question
on that one it's probably one of the
biggest evolving risks that all councils
are facing at the moment uh the high
needs block within so we get we have
four blocks schools block um secondary
block and the um
pioner
Grand 10
equals
to work with with the school en of that
to get it back on Target and as a
concession to take that out of our
accounts and hold it as a
Sear's po um so it doesn't contaminate
your main general fund financing
expenditure um so this this this is a
statutory override they call it so it's
separated from the council's finances
that it's due to expire in I think 2025
2026 so it will become an issue back for
the council but obviously it's a growing
nationally um some councils well we're
our our high needs lot deficit is
growing we brought forward an an
overspend of 4.5 million at the
beginning of the year we expect that to
be over 10 and a half million by the end
of this financial year we've had we have
regular discussions with the DFA in
terms of management of that
we were required to put in a deficit
management plan as to how
that anything versus if we
did talking about gaps growing to the
region of
35 take action or
45 with with other organizations other
the local authorities within within the
um within direct R to Manchester so that
there's a lot of activities in terms of
how case scenario
is you know debated all the
way all the way say this except we can't
keep ignoring
this specific U resource
um where they actually the D Fe step in
and say right we will give you
additional Resource One to balance your
budget in year and two to clear your
deficit off um there was something
in think it was cheser East are
actually our cash flow now we're
borrowing some 3 and half million
interest cost some to borrow the money
short call just
the um is something that
um within the council in terms of a
conclusion to it I think it needs to be
it's a national issue that doesn't seem
to
be
um
level to manage coming through the
system please just clarify when it's not
on
new
extion potentially
tens
spend
threat and I'm aware of it I'm not sure
how many members are
fully when Tech the statut
over
is that
liability they seems
there seems to
be down the road
in so again
it's yeah I'll come in
on
and where um I think it's
fair
numers of authorities were starting to
struggle the intention behind the statue
of the DFE need to understand whether
the problem is lack of money in the
system decision making
authorities
I think at the time said that they had
the resource to support and I want to
say it's eight or 10 authorities a year
to go through a a project with them to
look at how much of the issue was to do
with the way councils were making
decisions around the services they
wanted to provide versus how pressure um
if if that distinction kind of makes
sense
I they would address
it but if they were to stop at 26 you're
absolutely right that that problem is
coming back to the
council the difficulty I think is that
there are other parts of the leg
legislation around the way that your
funding for Education Works that
actually stops you putting money in to
to correct it so so that that's the real
difficulty is you can't solve it
anyway so that's why they've done it the
way they've done
it okay pressing news
but
I wondered
where um
extreme fed into
this
risk
number of different things that can go
wrong and the projects and
processes
off about making sure those overarching
processes are in place to deal
with
Services the question
is
the risk the one on the Leisure Services
it seems to be
Financial
find know the one I mean leure Serv
risk so what I'm trying to say is the
the climate risks the report seems to
talk
about risk actually is
to health polities addressing our
climate crisis Leisure Services it
doesn't say lot about what
the not having these Leisure Services in
terms of like our Public Health it just
talks about
financial
with the risk number five Leisure
although
under each uh director make sure they
link
to any of the risk so it LS to the
health
equalities R is more
around that
perhaps investment
focuses on
specific say yeah there's things you you
want to ask further
about two
meetings include more about
risk facilities in terms of their health
is that what you're saying or not in
this respect I think the the focus is
more around the the
finance updates on
that some
uh update
Mark yeah further updates on
uh Focus
um Financial system audits uh as well as
finalizing quite a few
school and reports five reports issued
ow or reasonable levels of
assurance um if we go
to page
171 a
listing reports uh We've produced during
the period um terms of
final um where we looked at things like
the
Financial
Rec s of strategic as well
acknowledging opinion level which
was mendations made at each school um
quite a few pieces of work that are
draft in the next update um reviews
around uh children's social care
payments whiches cards accounts
payable well as the the risk management
reporting
um continue to support the national
fraud initiative
so an
update um and also some work we've
been um we did Issue some guidance to
schools um start in around
July um basically sign
posting
how Services have
responded um all recommendations and
those four final reports agreed each
recommendation plan against
it largely in progress because there's a
number of followup audits um in progress
currently that we can report on next
time we did updates from previous School
audits previous recommendations have
been
implemented terms
of against the plan
there
um each area terms of the whole
um work
with we're up
to so we we feel we're on track uh for
the
year
of um there are a number of pieces of
work where State time to be
agreed in the remainder of the year in
the next financial
year section n of the report just
briefly talks about future
plan for the current P December and
there's there listing of a number of
final
reports that I can
uh update um which I'll I'll give in
February thanks very
much
on page
of
um points of information support got the
rag
rating
uh section five on page 171 basically
just refers to those opinion
levels there's an opinion level which is
the reasonable
one of those opinion levels so that
table in the back is just
explaining of those
green but it's the're both on the
appendant too they're both dark
green to slight slightly maybe they do
look a bit clear
slight
looks look into
that you worly putting your hand your in
a raise position there can car itching
your nose I think okay can we go it 12
with the uh work
program
okay me on the
program just just
as so we originally had star uh pres
today if we've agreed with st to come to
the
meeting to provide you
update ear the cyber security and
climate risk pram February
March um and as Frank mentioned earlier
there'll be a treasury management
briefing session
um and also just in terms of discussion
about
future around investment so
was one of the suggested ones we
we meeting Council C raised a m with me
about complaint you said you might
incorporate
that
um
I'm the
council's you knowes
andc
substantial
amount you know understand where that
money is coming
into flexibility there is over that very
obviously we hear a lot about
cutting
are we traditionally L council tax
um but in terms of if we
wanted
that is it possible
say go work out how to across the whole
of the Cil earn million pounds or
something like that a
year Poss en Council
corporate
the report
talk
discre things
so being able to do full cost
recovery need to turn it around quick
otherwise there penalties so there's
lots
examples like that Fe
care you start ruling out what your
discretionary income targets are what
you can
do well building control you you're also
against the private sector can also do
building control so so the the finance
team at the market sustainability
whether you
can
chares more to come back to see which
ones you might want to
investigate I mean we have a that we
come across in
terms reducing car
dependency finish grou that's skillfully
check
by we've been hearing examples of people
who are doing for
example perits
or you know by
um bigger engines the more fluting your
vehicle um the more
you fit into a
corporate
are there ways with things and maybe
other or
does earn us more money um overall but
Al there's
potential political as well I understand
that but we need to know what the
options
are yeah I mean iose I suppose when we
looking at
um themes these are the
ideas if this man in
it income generation plus supporting
the studies that
we to offices the budget thing that
would
support
last night's discussion perhaps we
us okay C
coun
under the general title of
program may ask
um sure that when the council invests in
it systems
Capital request goes in that
will
do
systematically of the delivery of the
benefits that were claimed in the
C we do does account and audit see
them I know
there's meetings in terms of that
investment I know a lot of the savings
there some chunks in the Savings
Program
investment of that um they are they are
I suppose they are reported to in
thematically
um within the
transformation
themes times so you
know head back in into it so
um think
of
what the larg two
Capital what was promised what was
delivered against that sa five you
wouldn't go
into
make
just lot Capital program
investment existing
systems necessarily on the ground the
same investor
rep are main frames the them
engineer won't remember used to come
here and ask for a million quid for a
new something to do with the main frame
everybody agreed because nobody knew
what he was talking
about then we spend two hours arguing
about something that cost 10,000
C future were I
wased by the um issue that uh Council
Carter raised about the um High needs
block I would hate to
get
toward
in that similarly this church
Commissioners one um the uh loss on
there in page
49 I also think we the two risks that I
would like us to look
at
we have
now CH change the
rules requirement is it there's very
little you can tap it because it's a
stat requirement to reide these
services
that we
can't children
services we are authority
to
always
quickly
to make conf the members Council AUD
committee together the church commission
investment as well that's
another that's
another
over the last
few
movement
okay okay
that problem
to short
informal MES after the after the
meeting